Now hopefully you have a little more context into the process
of projecting three dimensions into two for the purpose of creating a map.
And now we can begin drawing our world map in d3.
So to recap, we have a GeoJSON file, world_countries.json, that
we load in with our typical D3 JSON data loading file.
Calling our function draw once all the data's loaded.
And in our draw function, we've already set up the Mercator projection.
Now, we need to draw the SVG path to actually visualize the map.
Think of the projection in this case analogous to the scales we
used for our chart.
With scales, we converted a data value.
Either an integer or a float into a pixel value.
The mercator projection, while internally,
is much more complicated than something like a linear or logarithmic scale,
performed the exact same function, given a coordinate of longitude and latitude.
It spits back an x and y pixel.
And to actually create the SVG object.
That will represent the polygon of our map.
We used D3's geo.path.
Now even though the projection converts from longitudes and latitudes.
Into the pixel domain, we still need to construct the SVG objects, to correctly
render those pixels, and that's exactly what the D3.geo.path does.
And to let it know we're using the Mercator projection,
we can simply call the .projection method on the path,
passing in the projection we would like to use.
So let's put all these pieces together to actually draw the map with our data.
This bit of code I added should look very familiar to you by now, and
is similar to the code we used to draw our chart.
First, we select all of the paths in this case,
in our SVG since those are what were going to be adding.
And bind our GeoJSON data to this empty selection, it's empty
again since it's the first time we're drawing the map on our page, and notice
here that I'm not just using geo_data, but I'm using the .features already.
Remember geo_data actually at two top level keys.
And the .features key corresponded to the array of country coordinates.
And now with our bound data.
And again remember that this is an array of placeholder elements.
We then make the enter selection to select all the paths of countries.
That are not currently not on the page,
which is all of them since this is the first time we're drawing the map.
And for each of this, we want to append the path to our
SVG that has its d property set to this path object we created above.
SVG path elements are quite flexible and can represent most any shape, and
you simply pass the S series of vertices or points in the d attribute that can
be thought of as the data of the path, to specify the SVG path to actually draw.
Notice here that we simply pass.
The d3 path object without any arguments or
without using any callback successor function.
How does it know which country to draw then?